in DreamWorks animated movie the boss
baby 30 rock star Alec Baldwin lends his
voice to a business suit wearing
briefcase carrying baby whose arrival at
his family's home causes all sorts of
chaos yippie Kay movie lovers it's Jan
here and in my last video I revealed
some fun facts you probably didn't know
about the boss baby but now in this
video I want to let you in on some cool
Easter eggs hidden details and movie
references in the film before I get
started I'm giving away a second copy of
this amazing hardback book from Titan
called the art of the boss baby which
contains loads of concept art
storyboards and info about the movie all
you need to do for a chance to win is
subscribe and leave a comment on this
video about the boss baby movie or your
favorite Easter Egg from the film and
for bonus ways to enter check out the
gleam link in the video description
below okay quick warning there are
spoilers ahead so if you've not seen the
movie yet why not come back here after
you've seen the film when Tim and boss
baby's parents have to go on a work trip
to Vegas they leave their children at
home with a new babysitter eugenia who's
actually really France's he France with
his brother Eugene dressed up in women's
clothes this part of the film heavily
references Disney's 1964 classic movie
Mary Poppins just look at you Jr's
clothing including her little hat and
flower the way Francis II Francis calls
her practically perfect in every way the
way boss baby refers to her a scary
poppins and also the way she slide
through the air using her umbrella as
Eugenia aka Eugene chases them down the
street boss baby tells him he must cycle
faster if they're going to escape at
which point the movie takes us inside
Tim's mind where he imagines himself and
boss baby sailing on a stormy sea as
they're pursued by enormous whale with
the face of Eugenia this scene tipped it
packed the 1956 film Moby Dick and the
classic novel on which it was based also
during that chase scene through the
streets - imagines himself a boss baby
on a motorcycle jumping through a ring
of fire over a moving train which is a
little tribute to the many herbal and
stunts of the legendary daredevil
performer Evel Knievel if you are
thinking that Tim's talking alarm-clock
wizzy The Wizard sounds rather familiar
that's because actor James McGrath who
voices him is particularly skilled at
celebrity impressions and based with use
voice on actor Ian McKellen who's
famously played Gandalf in Peter
Jackson's Lord of the Rings and Hobbit
movies and the line
tough little halflings that wizzy says
every morning is also a nod to the
novels of JRR tolkien in which halflings
is another name for hobbits director
Steven Spielberg's iconic
action-adventure movies including the
Indiana Jones film for an inspiration
for the boss baby filmmakers
particularly when it came to creating
and editing the fantasy sequences dreamt
up in the movie by Tim so when Tim is
running through a jungle flying a
spaceship or fighting a gorilla the
movies editor channeled the editing
style youth and Spielberg's classic
movies but whip cracking archaeologist
Indiana Jones wasn't the only character
that inspired Tim's wild flight to
imagination the filmmakers also took
cues from the Looney Tunes cartoon
character Ralph Phillips who liked him
was a young boy with a vivid imagination
and a tendency to daydream likewise the
movie's graphic stylized look is also in
a marsh - Warner Brothers Looney Tunes
cartoons and several Disney films from
the Golden Age of animation influence
the movie - for example the fantasy
scene where Tim saved his parents inside
a shark by using hot sauce is a riff on
Disney's 1940 animated film Pinocchio
where Pinocchio starts a fire to escape
from the huge whale monstro that
swallowed him and his father Geppetto
another of director Steven Spielberg's
movies also left its mark on the
neighborhood where Tim's family lived
according to the boss baby director Tom
McGrath they set the movie in small-town
suburbia in a past that combines the
1970s and 80s and for the appealing look
of Tim's neighborhoods they took cue
from the much-loved early 80s movie et
you probably noticed that the magnetic
letters on the fridge change from Tim's
name to baby and that Tim's photo gets
covered over with baby pictures once
both baby arrived but what you might not
have spotted is that before boss baby
arrives
Tim is wearing a t-shirt with a number 1
on it however just after Tim spots boss
baby arriving in a taxi Tim doesn't
change his clothes but the number on his
t-shirt does change from 1 to 2 as he
rushes down the stairs to find out
what's going on which of course signals
that he no longer feels like number one
priority in the family during a big
action scene where Tim chases boss baby
and his toddler team around the
gardener's boss baby drives the toy cop
car there's a musical hat tip to the
theme tune of the 1970 of TV series SWAT
which followed the escapades with
special weapons and tactics team and the
movies action scenes also make use of
sound effects
the popular 1970s sci-fi action series a
Six Million Dollar Man which thought
actually majors as a special agent with
Bionic implants that gave him superhuman
abilities and of course because the
character of boss baby is brought to
life by actor Alec Baldwin the movie
includes the largest roles he's played
on the big and small screen for instance
during one of boss baby's meetings with
a special mission team of Stacey the
triplets and Jimbo there's a lovely nod
to another demanding businessman Baldwin
played in the 1992 movie Glengarry Glen
Ross in that film his character utters a
now famous lines put that coffee down
coffee's for closers and in this movie
that becomes put that cookie down
cookies upper closes which boss baby
says to Jimbo when he's turning him off
for eating cookies before they succeeded
in their mission the character of boss
baby also clearly plays on Alec
Baldwin's award-winning turn as
executive Jack Donaghy and the
critically acclaimed TV comedy 30 rock
the point that the movies business savvy
baby is pretty much a mini Jack Donaghy
in diapers barking orders spouting
management advice and talking about
corporate retreats and just like 30
Rock's Jack Donaghy who idolizes his
boss Don Geiss wanting to follow in his
footsteps and be promoted to the top job
when guys retires so - boss baby admires
his manager and is striving for a
promotion and a corner office of his own
now what're your favorite Easter Egg
hidden details and references in the
movie and did you spot any others I
missed let me know in the comments below
and don't forget to subscribe and
comment for your chance to win a second
copy of this fantastic the art of the
boss baby hardback book if you like this
video do also check out my boss baby
secrets video about the making of the
movie and also my animation playlist
here and as always I appreciate your
likes shares and comments on my videos
thanks for watching and see you next
time
yippie Kay movie lovers